What is this?
It is a fin. Fish have fins for swimming in water.
Do ducks have fins?
No, but they have flippers instead.
What are these?
They are wings. Birds have wings for flying in the air.
Look! Those animals have no legs, no wings and no fins.
How do they move?
They crawl on land.
Some animals have strong legs for hopping, and move on land.
Some animals have strong legs for running, and move on land.
Some animals have many legs for crawling, and move on land.
Some animals have two legs for walking, and move on land.
Some animals have wings for flying, and move in the air.
Some animals have fins for swimming, and move in water.
Some animals have long arms for swinging, and move in trees.
Others have no legs, no arms, no wings, no fins, and move on land.